[Music]  I wanted to get even more romantic with  Nick and explore Georgia sexually she is  good at stimulating chemistry between us  The Bachelor definitely found its  villain this season in 25 year-old  Karina elympios but could the villain  actually win I'm just full of number  ones so it's it's better than being  number two or going number two check out  this Instagram from social media  personality girl with no job Karina  definitely has a diamond ring on that  finger oh my gosh now et has reached out  to ABC and Warner Brothers the  production company behind the bachelor  about the pig but they had no comment so  we're just gonna have to wait and watch  I appreciate the fact that over time  people have gotten to see more of me and  they've been patient with me and I hope  they are as patient with the lippert as  they have been with me  [Music]